Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P I mentioned this a little
bit earlier in our segment about the Supreme
Court apparently imminently overturning Roe v
Wade. Here's a caller who's thinking along some
similar lines that I am. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: I think that this is key here for
Florida. The Supreme Court just put out a notice
to overturn Roe versus Wade. Yes. They think same
sex marriage is an. Interracial marriages is next.
I would love to hear your commentary. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, like I said earlier, I don't
know whether there will develop a concerted effort
to end interracial marriage at the state level
or to end gay marriage or. I don't I can't
say for sure that that's where energy is going
to be focused. But some of the people who are
against abortion are also against those things.
And there's nothing that will more invigorate
these reactionary movements than getting what
they see as a win. And this was a win that took
a while. Like I said earlier, it took Trump had
to win in 2016. Get his first opportunity to put
a Supreme Court justice on the court. The second
one. The third one. Then you needed to see these
state level abortion ban start to be put together
and then to be fought and then to be appealed to
the court. And then the court had to take one of
those cases. Okay. So it's a process, but it is
a win for them. There's no question about it.
And so, in general, when you get an inch, you
then try to take a mile. And I absolutely think
there will be some movement to go further and go
beyond just stopping abortion. I don't know if
it'll be interracial marriage, gay marriage rules
about employment or whatever else the case may be.
But they aren't going to stop here. That's
for sure. We have a fantastic bonus show
for you today. Campaign season is on. We have
primaries today in Ohio and in some other places,
and there are many more primaries this month.
We're going to talk about the midterms are now
happening on the bonus show. We will
talk about another Supreme Court
decision in which the Supreme Court has found
that First Amendment rights were violated when
a group wanted to put a Christian flag outside
of city hall. We'll talk about that. And what
Texas Republican Governor Greg Abbott has been
doing at the border between Texas and Mexico
has turned out to be an extraordinary economic
opportunity for the state of New Mexico. We will
talk about what's going on there as well.
All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman dot com. You
will get instant access to the bonus show. You'll
get the commercial free audio and video streams
of the show. Don't wait all day for clips to be
released of the show. You'll get the entire show
commercial free hours earlier than everybody else
when you become a member at Join Packman dot
com. I'll see you on the bonus show or otherwise
tomorrow. And reminder, Wednesday night. Tomorrow,
Wednesday night, May 4th. I will be live with the
next Pennsylvania Senate Republican debate. That's
the one with Mehmet Oz, the guy who suggests quack
cures on TV and other Republicans running for the
Republican nomination in that race tomorrow night.
We'll be live with that as well. See everybody
soon on the bonus show tomorrow. Tomorrow.